ces deux terrils font partie du paysage
autunois on les nomme l'été l'eau du nom
du quartier où ils ont été édifiés à
partir de 1813 autun abriter les plus
grandes mines françaises de schistes
bitumineux ont transformé en une sorte
de pétrole
l'activité a pris fin en 1957 et depuis
la nature a repris ses droits
petite visite d'une étonnante friches
industrielles au pied des terrils
on se retrouve soudain à marcher sur un
sol étranger
ce ne sont pas des rochers qui sont
recouverts de mousse mais des briques
réfractaires car ici de la fin du 19ème
à la seconde guerre mondiale il y avait
des fours
c'était là qu'était présent les fous qui
permettait à partir du schiste
bitumineux d'obtenir une huile qui était
très proche du pétrole donc on avait
trois rangées de four qui faisait une
petite vingtaine de mètres de haut
jean-philippe pas ça qui est historien
quentin barbotte naturaliste ce sont eux
qui nous guide dans la jungle d'été
l'eau avant de passer au four le schiste
arrivait dans le bâtiment des
concasseurs schiste était extrait à peu
près une centaine de mètres de
profondeur il était remonté par des
grands wagonnets est ici en fait ils
étaient déversés dans des trémies donc
ce sont les grand entonnoir qui sont
derrière nous il descendait
progressivement jusqu'à passer ensuite
dans ce qu'on appelle des concasseurs
donc ce sont des grands cylindres qui
permettait de broyer le schiste à la
taille idéale avant de le passer dans
les fours grimp ont maintenant jusqu'au
sommet d'un terril l'exploitation du
schiste a une particularité elle produit
plus de déchets que de matière
utilisable
c'est donc une petite montagne de
déchets que nous gravissent
une montagne constituer peu à peu qu'il
fallait sans cesse stabiliser pour
éviter qu'ils ne glissent comment les
déchets tête il hisser jusqu'au sommet
vous aviez un système de wagonnets avec
un câble qu'il l'ait tractait les
wagonnets étaient déchargés au sommet du
terril mécaniquement
ils redescendent est avide et c'est un
mouvement perpétuel et on considère que
les conditions de travail au sommet de
ces deux monticules était
particulièrement âpre particulièrement
du désormais le tumulte industrielle est
loin et force est revenue à la nature
d'abord les terrils ont été de simples
caunes totalement nue entassement de
déchets inertes et puis peu à peu on n'y
a vu s'installer une certaine végétation
surtout les espèces pionnières qui vont
développer donc celles qui peuvent se
développer sur un sol assez pauvre par
exemple le boulot là on en a bien un bon
exemple avec du boulot un peu partout
c'est vraiment lui qui peut arriver en
armes en tout cas à se développer le
plus facilement entre guillemets se re
sur ce type de milieu et on a le chêne
qui commencent à pousser un petit peu
avec la naissance d'une flore c'est
aussi toute une faune qui a pris ses
quartiers sur la montagne de schiste et
ses alentours
sur ce site on a recensé plus de 250
espèces de papillons aussi bien de nuit
que de jour batifole aussi des
libellules et notamment plusieurs
espèces d'algues riom
pour en savoir plus sur le passé
industriel d'été l'ocet au muséum
d'histoire naturelle d'autun qu'il faut
aller on peut y voir notamment de
magnifiques fossiles de reptiles et
d'amphibiens imprimé dans de grandes
plaques de schiste entre 1813 et 1957
la société minière employa jusqu'à 2000
sommes nulle part ailleurs en france la
filière schiste hier n'a connu un tel
développement qui s'est pourtant soldée
par une gabegie financière et une
production dérisoire c'est la grande
caractéristique de la filiale schiste
hier elle n'a jamais été rentable
c'est plutôt une industrie qui est lié
aux événements géopolitiques et en
général quand la france a besoin de
produits pétroliers
elle découvre où elle redécouvre la
filière schiste fière de cette aventure
du schiste à autun reste une friche
industrielle qui a donné naissance sur
les flancs d'été l'eau à une petite
forêt primaire un site surprenant et
poétique où l'on peut se promener en
toute liberté et découvrir un superbe
panorama